anyway so this crash didn't happen let's
move on let's say if a crash did happen
maybe there's some advice that you can
take let's move on to this next story
okay so if a crash did happen which is
possible again major crashes have
happened
three in the last
20 years they usually happen every 10
years or so there was one in 2000 2008
2020. so who knows when the next one
happened there's three things that
basically according to the motley fool
that you should not do if there's a
stock market crash are you ready to get
into these three things here are the
three things that you should not do if
there's a stock market crash number one
i wholeheartedly agree with
don't panic sell
don't panic don't panic don't panic
don't panic all right investing should
not be emotional investing
should be watching like grass grow
should not be exciting i always say that
you know the wolf of wall street jordan
belford made stock investing or stock
trading exciting
and then he ended up in jail and i was
worth minus 100 million dollars
stock market investing should be
freaking boring compound interest as
exciting as it may be in your portfolio
ain't exactly exciting it should be
watching like paint dry over time you
build wealth i like getting rich slow
i like building wealth over time i i
don't freak out
like every day i'll look at the uh the
my apple app and i see the market's red
the market's green it's up but over time
the market grows at about 10 uh year
over year okay i know that stock market
we're talking the stock market here
david all right so number one is don't
panic sell if someone tells you the
stock market is going down if you see
the market just chill out bro don't let
your emotions get the best of you so it
actually there's a funny little study
right there fidelity major bank i
actually bank with them major wire house
you know how they said the most
successful investors they have are
they basically said the most successful
investors they had are either dead
or forgot they had an account lol why
because they weren't panic selling right
i mean they were dying right um or they
forgot they had account and they just
left their money in the market yeah the
point is just leave it leave it in there
let it marinate let compound interest do
their thing don't try to trade don't try
to time the market don't try to buy the
dip don't try to get in and get out so
you you wouldn't consider so you
wouldn't suggest that if something's
down instead of panic selling maybe hey
take it as it's on sale tesla's on sale
yes get some so
buy the dip
well it's the the the trick with that is
when do you know the dip is if the
market's at 38 right now 36 and it goes
down to 30 oh it's the dip then it goes
down to 25. oh is that the then it goes
to 22. all right now it's coming back up
like
it's impossible so there's something
called dollar cost averaging that's what
i've done since i'm 27 years old now i'm
40. okay dollar cost averaging is
basically saying i don't know where the
market is today i don't know where the
smp is today but every paycheck this is
a hot tip for everyone out there every
paycheck i'm throwing some money in the
market boom paycheck 10 going in boom 10
so every year i max out my 401k that's
19 000 a year when i was making less
than 120 grand at a certain point i'd
max out my roth ira and if you make more
than a certain uh amount you can do
maybe a backdoor roth ira there's tax
incentives tax advantages you can put in
about six grand in your roth ira if you
don't have an employee if you have
employee match that's free money baby
take that money but the point is you
can't be panic selling
and especially if you're young
you've got time on your side it's like
i'm going to say like people are going
to say
sas you already said that you know you
already said this they can't
but that's my point is it's the same
concepts over and over and over again i
say this every week david 50 of money
and your financials
is knowledge okay i get it i understand
i have a 401k i understand saving but
the other 50 is behavioral are they
actually freaking doing it
are you actually getting out of debt are
you actually putting 10 of your paycheck
into your 401k i think are you actually
doing it that's the hard part yeah and
that's what most people don't do is put
it into practice yeah oh a roth ira oh
that's sick man yeah yeah i know about a
raw thought right anyway yeah yeah i
heard that's great are you putting money
in there no what are you waiting for
so
again the most successful investors are
either dead or forgot they had an
account there's there's a there's a
lesson there is that just keep your
money in the market again vesting is
long-term long-term whether that's five
years in a brokerage account or a roth
ira whether that's freaking 40 years in
your 401k
let the pasta sauce marinate yeah let it
marinate you know it's like if you ever
walk into an italian grandma's kitchen
don't attach to the pasta sauce
she wants to marinate it that's what's
going on let it simmer let it simmer let
it cook okay you know warren buffett's
famous line when it comes to risk and
investing right
i think it was like in 1986 he had a
shareholder meeting famous line and
basically he says
we
attempt to be fearful
when others are greedy and we attempt to
be greedy when others are fearful do you
understand what i'm saying be greedy
when people are fearful and be fearful
people are greedy so when people are
getting too greedy yeah and oh
everyone's making money everyone's
making money on bitcoin everyone's
making them on nfts all this those coins
going up be very fearful yeah
but when everyone's panicking everyone's
selling everyone's oh my god the world's
coming to an end
now's the time to be greedy
and invest
so don't follow the crowd is basically
what this is don't panic cell there's
always going to be hype in the news
there's always going to be people
telling you the news
the the financial news media
if they actually could
tell you stories that are new
they'd run out of stories because it's
the same
hey
five ways to make more money six ways to
improve your wealth eight ways to uh
invest it's the same stuff
understand getting out of debt
understand interest rates working
against you understand that you need to
have an emergency fund and you need to
have a cost you need to save that money
understand investing long term keep it
simple keep your calls low it's the same
stuff right but they got to spin it in a
million different directions so they can
sell papers or sell viewership it's the
same stuff like i wish i was reinventing
the wheel here over here telling you to
save that money no
the richest man in babylon it was a book
that i read 10 000 years ago when it was
written whatever it was it's the same
stuff that's applicable today have a
budget have a game plan for your money
understand what's going on with your
money
debt is your money going backwards right
right
uh save that money you're gonna need it
for sure invest compound interest have
insurance protection emote around your
castle back in the day now that's life
insurance or disability insurance or
health insurance and last but not least
retirement what i call
chilling it's the same stuff
it's just a different terminology anyway
that's what um
uh that's number one i'm sorry i'm
ranting here david hey three things you
should not do if there's stock market
number one don't panic cell what's your
point anyway because when you panic sell
that's like taking an l nobody wants to
take an l you only take an l when you
sell take an l when you sell that rhymes
okay number two
number two
don't ignore
the business the actual business like
tiesto
let's get down let's get down to
business
you hate that song i think it's
we've had a million million nights just
like this i hate it but let's get down
let's get down to biz anyway
don't get distracted by essentially
where the price of the stock is or the s
p is or the price of the index the most
important factor is that you're
understanding that you're when you're
investing in a stock you're investing in
an actual
business with real profits or real
losses
and supposedly long-term agendas so
understand that when the market's up and
the market's down
there's there's a story behind it and
that are actual businesses there's our
actual maybe 500 businesses in the s p
and they're gonna do all right over time
understand that so basically what i'm
saying is stay rooted in reality okay
the businesses are going to get down to
business don't really don't don't forget
you know the rumors the gossip the
kaiser kiyosaki saying their crash
don't ignore the business these these
companies are still making profits right
app microsoft i think just took over
apple as the most uh
as the
number one company in the world oh yeah
okay
sorry yeah in terms of market cap yeah
all i heard at first was microsoft took
over apple i was like no no no in terms
of market cap all right number three why
you shouldn't what you should should not
do there's a stock market crash
don't stop investing part wait you said
number three number three there's three
reasons number one don't panic sell
number two don't ignore the business the
business model that are going on these
companies number three don't
stop investing don't stop
investing
cool yeah
can you sing that song
just uh just the miami boy
he's born and raised in south beach
he's been the strip clubs and live all
night long yeah okay anyway
number three is don't stop it but don't
stop believing don't stop investing we
talked about dollar cost averaging right
keep on keeping on keep on keeping on
every paycheck boom i'm putting 100
bucks in every paycheck whether the s p
is at 2 000 or 4 thousand the stock the
dow is at
twenty thousand forty thousand whatever
it is i'm keeping putting money in
whether bitcoins at thirty thousand or
sixty thousand if you believe in bitcoin
every month every paycheck put another
hundred bucks put another thousand bucks
that's what's called dollar cost
averaging and this account okay i'm just
kidding and that's a very simple way
to basically avoid making
emotional mistakes
stop overthinking i don't know is the
market going up is it going down is it
going left is it going right you just
keep on investing whether that's in your
401k your auth ira your bitcoin your
brokerage account whatever if you
believe in the asset class you believe
that the world is not ending just keep
on keeping out
don't stop
anyway so essentially it doesn't matter
if the market's high if the market's low
it doesn't matter what happens with that
dollar cost averaging don't stop
investing okay so again i've lived
through three crashes okay 2000 when i
basically was in college i couldn't
spell investing at that point certainly
couldn't spell 401k that's for sure
2008 when i started investing basically
i think i started i started investing
there like uh how much money did you
lose i'm like nothing i literally just
started investing like last week nothing
okay
and i've been maxing out all my stuff
401ks roth iras all my brokers much
putting up money as much money into that
since 2008 from
2008-2020 there was the longest bull
market in
american history and i've seen the money
grow and grow and grow and grow and grow
and i tuned out the noise you know how
long over the last before covert i mean
there's a market crash the market crash
oh my god what's happening next i just
tuned out the noise
boglehead's guide to investing i talk
about that book right jack bogle
vanguard tune out the noise keep your
costs low stay the course it's simple if
you actually can tune out the noise so
there's going to be a lot of
distractions it's going to be ignore all
the kiyosaki predictions all that just
keep on keeping on if you're young for
sure now if you're old
you know i've done this thing before
yeah if you're young have a lot in
stocks little in bonds right if you're
20 30 something stock up
bond low now if you're old if you're 70
if you're 80 and there's a crash coming
you better be in 75 80 bonds so even if
there is a crash you've got your bonds
stabilizing your portfolio it's actually
not that complicated when you just
understand this whole thing
this is what it is david let me see one
of these from you baby
yeah if you're at home you're watching
this give one of these yeah yeah you
want to give one of these too up what's
up hey all right now we're up here now
we're up here
the point is this if you're young don't
let this
the nonsense the news distract you from
your long-term goals save that money
invest that money tune out the noise
stay the course there's the advice right
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken